do you did you have a bad relationship
we're good relationship with Gale Berman
who's there good I had a good
relationship with everybody executive
producer I felt bad for her because she
was the one who had to tell me that I
was fat she didn't want to do oh I bet
she would yeah she didn't want to do it
he's not skinny
no she shots five she was so upset and I
feel bad because it's not really her
fault she's just a messenger
ya know and I never really got to make
that right with her I never I haven't
seen her
yeah she's great yeah I mean she was the
president of Fox when I was on mm-hmm
mad yeah she was the one where okay so
that girl that girl that I brought to
the up front so I met this girl she
wanted to be a comedian but she had
never done stand-up before him and I I
wanted to have sex with her but she
didn't she wasn't attracted to me
physically but she was using me to go to
the [ __ ] New York oh that's right
yeah right so she she's like I want to
make it you know and and the first night
we were there I tried to make a move
yeah I just want to be friends so now I
have this girl in my hotel room for two
days at the other ones so we have this
gigantic dinner at you know some [ __ ]
gala thing and all the Kiefer Sutherland
everyone's there right because they're
on Fox shows so we all have tables and I
don't know where she is like I look over
to my left and I see her from across the
[ __ ] banquet hall yeah she's giving
her a [ __ ] business card to Gayle
Berman I'm a comedian riot and I you
know my brother's right yeah yeah Dre's
oh I [ __ ] grabbed a risk and I
[ __ ] dragged her back like an animal
I go if you know babe you don't [ __ ]
the president of Hawks
you don't that's not how you make it you
don't go to the president of farms
headshot would have been worse oh she
would have died killed it I would I
would have taken a [ __ ] I know what a
killer I would have just completely
disassociated okay I don't know that
girl you didn't have to now and she
can't go what table she had oh she's at
the MADtv table with who Bobby Lee
I'm [ __ ] also they're just friends
he's not [ __ ] [ __ ] in the friend
zone oh my god it was a disaster anyway
that's how I know Gayle and I know that
she was your executive producer yeah you
know Gayle nice lady is a nice lady and
my friend you know and I haven't seen
her but I think she's great she's great
yeah yeah yeah yeah
[Music]